Hello world,
it's Saroj and isn't scheduling a pain.
And this video,
what you're seeing behind me is what we're going to build.
It's a slack Bot that can schedule meetings for you.
So you just say,
I want to schedule a meeting with this person at this specific time.
And what it will do is they will go through their process of going through both
your calendar and that person's calendar looking for if,
if that time works,
if it doesn't work,
it will.
Then if it doesn't work,
it's going to try it another time.
It's just going to keep going until it finds a time for you guys to meet with no
conflicts.
And it's using AI in the way that it's being able to read your texts through
natural language processing and convert that into an action.
Or in our case we can call it an intent.
Okay,
so that's what we're going to build in this video.
And this is very useful for recruiting firms.
It's useful for teams,
it's useful for,
you know,
anybody who needs to schedule meetings and doesn't want to have to worry about
that back and forth.
You know what I'm talking about?
Between emails of,
Oh,
can you meet on this day?
Oh no,
that's not okay.
How about this day statewide,
it's a lot of time.
It's a lot of brain process and AI can take over for us.
Okay.
So this is how scheduling can be applied to many industries,
but the industry we're going to focus on in this video is recruiting.
Okay?
So there's a lot of different technology that recruiters use to help speed up
that pipeline,
right?
So from natural language processing,
you know,
reading resumes,
analyzing the text within a resume,
summarizing it's giving it each candidate a score automatically,
let's say out of a hundred,
being able to sift through all the dozens of applications that they're getting,
uh,
being able to say,
well,
this candidate is a specific fit for this job,
or know this candidate is actually a better fit for this job.
Uh,
that's all natural language processing people analytics,
right?
All of your social media information says a lot about you,
And so you know it,
it can be kind of scary,
but employers and potential potential employers can learn a lot about you
without you even having met them in real life before rights that can analyze
your Facebook,
your Twitter feeds,
you know,
your cloud score,
et cetera.
And they can learn what kind of person you are.
Sentiment analysis is another great example.
If recruiters wants to see what would be a good potential pool of candidates,
they can say,
well here is my brand.
Let's see what percentage of users on Twitter are expressing a positive
sentiment about my brand.
And they are technically adept,
or at least they're adept to be a good fit for this role.
So people who are good fits and like by brand,
let me reach out to them,
right?
So there's a lot of things that recruiters have to do just manually that they
can automate with AI across the entire pipeline.
And this applies to recruiting,
but it also applies to anybody who wants to use AI to increase their
productivity in a business environment.
So scheduling interviews is a very,
very time consuming process.
How can we increase productivity here?
Right?
So that's what we're going to build is this slack scheduler Bot.
It's in Java script and we're going to be using certain technologies to build
it.
Then I'll talk about right after I get through this very short history of
recruiting.
So there are five ways that recruiting is changing because of Ai.
One is the advent of,
of course,
big data.
There's so much out there that if you're not using it,
whatever industry,
even recruiting agriculture,
any,
if you're not using big data to make decisions,
you are objectively doing it wrong.
The decline of job portals,
right?
So in the,
in the late 1990s,
uh,
monster.com popped up,
a bunch of job board websites popped up and they were a way to move away from
newspapers and classified ads to the Internet for candidates to then post their
jobs there.
And then they could then find the relevant companies that would hire them.
But the problem is that this,
there's been a decline here in,
in job portals because in a network to the digital era,
there's not as much of a neat to do that.
There are different ways to find companies that you're interested in.
They're not necessarily job portals.
Word of mouth,
social media.
That's true.
That's another one.
Linked in get hub,
crowdsourcing talent.
It's becoming very popular.
And also it's becoming a world where remote work is becoming the norm.
And that's,
I'm not saying it's a norm right now,
but it is becoming the norm.
And because of that,
there's all these micro entrepreneurs that these companies are now hiring that
are not necessarily fulltime employees.
They're on demand employees and even very big companies,
traditional companies are moving towards this model.
And the last point is experience losing premium.
So the world is changing so fast because of AI and it skills get dated fast.
So degrees and experience are losing their edge as learnability and adaptability
are more important skills in this increasing market.
And just listen your degree and listen to your,
you know,
static experience is not as important as how adaptable you are,
as,
as how driven you are.
And that's something that you can't just list in a resume,
but big data can help inform that decision,
right?
So there are major factors that are affecting the recruiting industry right now
that there is a,
and the reason I say this is because there's a huge opportunity to apply AI to
this field because of these trends.
One,
all the baby boomers,
those are people born in the fifties sixties postwar are beginning to retire and
vacate jobs.
So there's going to be more job openings to SAS is on the rise.
Again,
building a second tech boom software as a service companies,
they're rising.
Social media is becoming very commonplace and younger generations are used to
this social media outlet.
So you're,
what you're saying is more job openings and more people applying for jobs so
that the market is increasing on both ends.
So just huge opportunity to help both ends of those markets.
Right?
So what does that,
what does that saying about the gold rush?
More people made money giving a shovels to the gold miners and the ones actually
fishing for gold.
Only a very small percent percentage of those people actually found goal.
But the people who were smart gay built shovels to sell to those gold miners.
And that was the same case for cryptocurrency rights.
You know,
very few people may a lot of money off of cryptocurrency even though it seems
like everybody is.
But the people who really made money were the people built businesses Asex
[inaudible] mining rigs,
you know,
different cloud mining solutions to help those people in there get rich quick
schemes.
The same can be applied to the recruiting industry.
What tools can you make to help recruiters improve the efficiency of their
pipeline?
What tools can you make to help candidates that are assessed their own profiles
and improve them?
So,
you know,
there are a lot of different websites that are,
that are offering tools for all of these things.
One example is reo,
right?
So Aria is automated AI sourcing.
What a recruiter can do is they can just type in a keyword and say,
I want a candidate that fulfills these,
these fields.
It will then crawl the web to find those candidates.
So it just imagine how much AI it's using in the background,
right?
It's,
it's taking certain keywords.
It's then searching for candidates that fit those keywords and they're suitable
for your job description because there's so much data out there,
it's,
it has to be able to segment that data and find the quality data out there.
One that I think is very cool is Clara.
So Clara labs is an,
is an AI assistant for scheduling emails.
So Clara labs is a very cool,
because what it does is it allows the candidate to book more interviews and
focuses on each candidate.
So it you're,
you're able to say,
okay,
I'm going to CC Clara,
right?
So if you're a recruiter and you want to,
you know,
schedule an interview with a potential job candidate,
you can just cc Clara,
which is an AI.
It's all in AI and say,
I'd love to show you a demo.
Let's,
how about Tuesday?
And then Clara,
we'll take it from there without having their need to be a back and forth.
What Clara is doing,
the reason it's an AI is it's using natural language processing to understand
the sentiment,
the,
the intent behind different texts and then coordinates via the Google calendars
for both,
for both parties.
And all of this is done automatically,
which is very cool.
And they built a multimillion dollar business in just two years,
which is incredible.
It's incredible.
And there's a lot of room,
uh,
for,
for this to happen.
This is an right,
this is one use case,
right?
Recruiting X.
Dot.
Ai is doing,
do these for different industry.
Thin is doing this for travel planning.
There's a lot of different industries,
but the basic idea remains the saying save people time and money and you will
succeed in what your,
whatever your startup is.
I should be doing this right now.
I should be.
But the thing is,
I'm,
I'm making so much revenue from what I'm doing right now that I just,
um,
I'm,
I'm pretty happy.
So,
so what,
what,
what I'm trying to say is that scheduling is different.
If you're a salesperson and your sales team is measured by the total number of
meetings you've scheduled,
right?
So it's not like every single industry is going to be,
you know,
optimized by the fact that they have meetings.
Right.
But some like recruiting,
well let's get into the technology.
I've talked enough about the background here.
So what is the architecture of what we're going to build?
So this is an Ai Bot.
It's a slack Bot and what it's going to do is it's going to use four different
technologies.
The first one is api.ai.
I made a video for them back in the day,
like a year and a half ago.
And then they got bought out by Google.
But it is,
it is a machine learning tool used to process natural language.
It's very,
very cool.
Uh,
basically,
I mean they renamed it to dialogue flow once Google bought it,
but it's the same backend.
So if you type in api.ai,
you'll go,
you'll go to the website.
And basically what it lets you do is say,
you know,
what I want is for all of these different phrases to result in the same
response.
So,
and it's it,
it uses machine learning,
right?
So you can say,
hello world,
what's up?
You know,
that's a different training phrase.
How are you,
you know,
how are you doing?
And then it's what it's going to do is it's going to,
uh,
create a vector representations of all of those sentences.
So there is a single vector representation that encapsulates every single
response that you've input to the model.
This is different from a hardcoded bought,
because you can say a couple of training phrases,
you might not have all of them rights,
but you can say a couple.
And what it's gonna do is it's going to find this semantic similarity between
different words.
And the way it does that is work to,
Beck is one example of an algorithm that does this.
It converts words into vectors.
And if you think about a word,
right,
if you think about a word,
it's a collection of ones and zeroes,
right?
It's,
it's just numbers behind it's a string.
And there is one representation that can represent all the different words that
are spelled differently,
but they really have the same meaning.
So how are you and how are you doing and what's going on?
Those are,
those are spelled totally differently,
but they have the same intent until what api.ai does is it lets you define an
intent.
So in this example,
I'm defining an intent as welcome,
right?
So in the welcome intent,
if a user says any of these things,
and this is training data that I'm giving it to in addition to other texts that
it learns,
right?
So you can give it a data set of texts or you can say,
here's,
here's the words and then just learn the vector representation.
The intent behind all of this and if anything that a user says is,
is even remotely close to the responses that I've typed in,
it's going to hit that intent and it's an output.
The predefined response right here that I can say,
you know,
the response is going to be,
good day greetings,
I'm doing fine.
Whatever you want,
So it's not a fully,
um,
general artificial intelligence chat Bot.
It's not a hard coded Chat Bot.
It's a very happy medium between those two.
So that's one example.
That's,
that's the machine learning tool that we can use.
There are so many of these tools out there.
Ibm's Watson,
uh,
Alexa,
you know,
uh,
this api.ai are so many out there that makes,
making chatbots were conversational interfaces and very,
very easy if you're not building one,
and you should be,
because messaging apps are the new social media since last year,
more users are using messaging apps and they're using social media.
If you're not using,
if you're not building a chat Bot,
if you haven't built a chat bot yet,
you should do that after this video,
or at least pause the video,
subscribe to my channel,
and then then build a chat bot.
It's very easy.
You're going to feel fulfilled.
You can put something on your get hub repository.
You'll feel good about yourself.
Definitely do that.
Okay.
If you haven't yet.
But anyway,
the other tool is slack.
So slack,
I mean we have a slack channel for this,
for this community.
And slack was originally made for teams,
but we kind of,
I think we're,
we're almost breaking it by the fact that we have 18,000 users in this slack
channel.
It was never meant for this many people,
but slack is great.
I love it.
Uh,
the community loves it.
If you haven't joined the slack,
you should,
you should join at Lincoln at the video description.
But that's going to be the medium for us to interact our AI to interact with the
users.
But remember,
if there can be different mediums,
we can use email,
we can use,
um,
you know,
Facebook messenger,
but we're going to choose slack for this example.
Google calendar Api.
That's the other tool we're going to use because we're,
we're going to have to have our AI have access to both our calendar and that
that's the third parties calendar,
right?
And so they have to be able to authenticate with Google to do that.
And lastly,
it's expressed.
So you know the mean stack writes a Mongo express angular node,
right?
That's the javascript stack for building a standards centralized web APP.
We're going to use express to create a backend server.
So here are the steps.
Let me give you the steps here.
When our slack Bot is sent a message,
like schedule a meeting with a person at a time on a specific date,
what it's gonna do is it's going to send that request,
that NLP request to api.ai just like this.
It's going to send it to api.ai via their API.
It's going to hit an intent that we defined that that is a predefined intent.
Setting up meetings,
writes the schedule or bottle,
then check to see if it has permissions to add events to both users.
So we just use the api.ai,
um,
API,
and now we're using the Google calendar Api to check.
It will then check both calendars to see if there are any preexisting conflicts.
If there are,
then the bottle responds saying,
Hey,
you know,
there are conflicts.
Let's reschedule.
Then that sends it up to the intense,
again,
if not boom in books,
but it keeps repeating that checking process until it finds suitable times for
you.
And it's very easy because it's going to offer different times.
So you don't,
you can just click on which ones you want to use.
You don't have to like say you know,
between this side it's very simple and this is all done juke [inaudible] using
Java script.
Okay.
So that was quite a short textual explanation behind it before we get to the
code.
But I really just wanted to get to the code for this one.
So let's,
let's get into the code here.
Okay.
So,
uh,
there's,
there's quite a lot of code but I think really the key code that we can go over
here is inside of this RTM client that Jay has function specifically in the
process message function.
What it's doing is inside of this process,
message function is being,
this function right here is being called whenever the Chat Bot is,
is activated.
So that is whenever a user sends a message to the Chat Bot like,
hello,
I want to schedule a meeting.
Boom.
This function is called right here.
This is the function that is sending that,
that query,
that text query to api.ai that getting that intense and then retrieving the
response.
So inside of this,
uh,
inside of this block right here,
we're sending that message as a query to api.ai.
We're adding the essential headers to make sure that the API call goes through.
And once we do that,
we're going to get a call back.
Okay?
So the call back,
we'll say,
please accept or decline the previous reminder if,
if we're trying to schedule a reminder,
if not,
it's a,
so,
and this is all the reminder code.
If not,
if it's a meeting that you're trying to schedule,
not a reminder,
it's going to say,
okay,
here is the intent,
which is called meeting.ad,
right?
So we will have an intent specific for adding meetings to our calendar.
And we can do this with Api Audit Ai.
Once we get that,
we can store that in this array right here called the invite array.
Now for however many people you want to add to the meeting,
we're going to iterate through all of them.
So for each user,
okay,
so for each user and all of their calendars,
we're going to say let's get that user and then,
and then once we were treated,
that user will create a new meeting.
Okay?
So we're creating a new meeting variable right here as a new meeting,
and we're going to define it by the user id,
by the Channel Id in this slack channel,
whatever the subject is,
the date,
the time,
the invitees,
these are the details of the meeting,
okay?
And so once it has those things,
it's going to check for conflicts,
right?
So inside of this check for conflicts with all of those users,
that can be one user,
it could be 50 users,
but it's going to check for conflicts between all of those users.
And once it does that,
it's going to check for conflicts.
And then if there is a conflict,
that's where the Google Api comes in,
right?
It's going to check all those conflicts.
It'll say,
would you like me to create the following meeting?
Right?
And then so you'll say yes or no,
and depending on what you say,
it's going to give you a different response.
So a lot of this looks like hardcoded code,
right?
It's like,
well either you know this is a good start time,
here's a good end time,
or sorry,
there was a scheduling conflict and then you can retry again and again and
again.
But the point is that it's using AI for natural language processing.
I want to end this video with giving you some great resources to look at.
So besides api.ai,
if you,
if you ever want to look at too into some of the,
the the really cutting edge techniques and natural language processing,
definitely checkout,
archive sanity.
So just type in natural language processing.
Just like this.
For me,
I'm very excited about natural language processing.
It's,
it's one of my,
one of my favorite sub fields of machine learning because there's so much there,
right?
We speak in language,
we,
we think in language and there's a lot of potential to do great things with
machine learning with NLP.
So once you type in natural language processing,
type in most recent,
and then what it's gonna do,
it's going to give you the most recent papers that cutting,
cutting,
cutting edge papers right here.
Like this one for example,
released just yesterday,
learning image to image translation using paired and unpaired training,
uh,
samples,
visual globalization,
a superconducting apple optoelectronic neurons.
There's a lot of stuff here.
Um,
and it might require some knowledge of different fields of science,
like you know,
this one,
but this one looks pretty cool.
Pop,
polite dialogue generation without parallel data,
polite dialogue generation.
That's,
that's pretty cool.
So NLP,
great subfield of machine learning.
Um,
I think a great course on NLP,
uh,
is taught by Michael Collins.
If you want to see more on NLP.
This is the one right here.
Michael Collins.
Yes,
yes,
yes.
Where are the videos?
Oh,
they're on Coursera if you follow this link,
but um,
oh,
come on.
Yeah,
here.
Right on Youtube.
So in this last week of the class.
So here's the playlist right here.
Uh,
but my point is that Michael Collins is a great NLP professor.
He was one of the,
he was one of my inspirations actually at Columbia when I took NLP there.
Um,
I was lucky enough to take it with him and I later met him a few years later
when I just walked,
actually,
like this was a few months ago.
I just walked in to Columbia and I saw him there and you know,
it took a selfie with him.
You know,
I took a selfie with him because to me,
he's like,
dude,
you know,
the Ai God.
And,
um,
it was cool.
It was cool.
But uh,
yeah,
that one,
our current sanity,
Michael Collins Nlp course,
and when it comes to recruiting an AI,
there is a lot of potential and I hope that you build something you put on your
get hub,
uh,
whether it's for recruiting or any industry,
um,
it's gonna,
it's gonna help people learn a lot.
So you've got to learn by doing,
get hubby's really,
you know,
Google for code.
So if there's any idea that you have,
if there's anything that you're,
that you,
that you think would be a good idea to build,
it's always best to search,
get hub first,
right?
So if I want to build a recruiting tool for,
um,
for recruiters using ais,
I would search recruiting AI and then there we go.
We have some different examples.
You know,
one thing I do is I looked her python examples,
right?
So python is generally,
you know,
more Ai.
If it's not python,
it's,
you know,
it could be anything,
not necessarily Ai.
And once we do that,
here we go,
um,
Rhonda Ai a year ago,
boom.
Just like that.
Ideally they have a read me,
I also sort by most stars.
So generally the Bourns with most stars have the most developer activity.
So that are the most updated.
But yeah.
Anyway,
I just wanted to give you that as those final examples.
Check out the code for this.
It's in the Github.
Read me and thanks so much for watching.
Please subscribe for more programming videos.
And for now I've got to go to Google io.
So thanks for watching.